[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée dans les Yvelines
avec au menu de l'actualité des infos
pratiques et des idées de sortie voici
le programme de ce mardi 14 mars
semaine décisive pour la réforme des
retraites la commission mixte paritaire
doit trancher sur un texte final demain
avant un vote au Sénat et à l'Assemblée
nationale jeudi et demain une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation contre le projet
de loi doit se tenir à l'appel de
l'Inter syndicale quelles sont les
perturbations après bord dans les
Yvelines ils n'ont fait le point ça
vient de débuter la 21e édition du
festival à tout bout de champ se tient
jusqu'au 2 avril à Manille et hameaux
spectacle et concerts pour toute la
famille sont au programme à la Maison de
l'Environnement l'estaminet et au pôle
Blaise Pascal on en parle avec Émilie
dubuck et Cécile Vandervoort du service
culturel de Magny-les-Hameaux et puis
les chineurs ils ont rendez-vous jusqu'à
dimanche la 104e foire de Chatou se
tient sur l'île des Impressionnistes 300
exposants venus de toute la France
propose sur place objet d'art livre ou
encore peinture
on en parlera tout à l'heure avec comme
tous les mardis également les insolites
de Véronique Ithurbide qui sera avec
nous en plateau ses infomance ces
informations qui vous ont peut-être
échappé sur le territoire des Yvelines
également Régine ralech qui est déjà
avec moi la rédaction de tv78 bonsoir
Régine bonsoir dans un instant avec vous
on va faire le point sur les
informations à retenir de ce mardi avec
14 mars et dans les Yvelines aussi des
invités tout à l'heure le festival à
tout bout de champ des invités aussi qui
sont avec moi en plateau déjà il y a
Charles-Antoine albizetti bonsoir élève
au lycée Hoche vous faites partie de
cette classe de défense et de sécurité
globale on va présenter justement ce
dispositif du ministère d'éducation
nationale en quelques mots qu'est-ce que
cette classe
autour donc des armées donc nous on est
en partenariat avec la gendarmerie
nationale donc ça permet donc le
développement personnel des jeunes
favoriser l'engagement et leur mobilité
surtout que quand on voit que la guerre
est au porte de l'Europe mais ça permet
de d'avoir de nouveaux hommes dans nos
armées on va parler de cette de cet
engagement également de votre part au
sein de cette classe de défense et de
sécurité globale à vos côtés il y a
Samuel Amiens bonsoir vous êtes le
bassiste du groupe saymanistes un trio
de jazz originaire des Yvelines et vous
serez ce weekend du côté d'Élancourt
pour la fête de la réouverture de la
médiathèque des 7 mars on va en parler
dans un instant je salue également votre
co-fondateur Yann Garreau qui est
batteur du groupe qui devait être avec
nous ce soir en plateau malheureusement
victime d'une extinction de voix donc
c'est un peu difficile de faire une
interview dans ces conditions en
quelques mots l'univers de saymani
qu'est-ce que c'est la musique sur
toutes ces formes binaires ternaires des
mesures ampères enfin tout toutes sortes
d'influence avec le jazz quand même au
cœur de tout enfin de mélodie qui sont
plutôt entraînantes effectivement pas de
chanteurs puisque la musique est au cœur
du projet on aura l'occasion aussi dans
d'en parler dans un instant dans cette
émission également découverte de l'expo
cabane elles sont mises à l'honneur ses
cabanes en ce moment du côté du palais
le droit de Rome a rambouillé retour sur
le festival régional du court-métrage
c'était au Clayes-sous-Bois ce dimanche
et puis comme chaque mardi également
l'astuce du chef honneur ce soir à la
cuisine libanaise avec le caviar
d'aubergine c'est marqué Badaoui qui
nous donne sa recette du taska mezzeba
c'est le nom de son restaurant il nous
donne la recette ce soir du caviar
d'aubergine mais tout ça ce sera bien
sûr après les prévisions météo de demain
un soleil timide c'est ce qui vous
attend malheureusement demain dans les
Yvelines demain matin des éclaircies
seront présentes sur tout le département
côté température il fera à 5 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Houdan et Rambouillet il
fera un tout petit peu plus chaud du
côté de Versailles avec 6 degrés pas de
changement ce qui concerne l'après-midi
les températures seront légèrement au
plus chaudes comptées 11 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan il fera 10
degrés à Versailles et Rambouillet et ce
mercredi 15 mars c'est la sainte Louise
on fait le point tout de suite sur les
informations du jour dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
et on débute tout de suite ces
actualités du jour Régine par une action
menée du côté de du magasin Castorama
par la CGT tout à fait Grégory depuis
plusieurs semaines la CGT Castorama
revendique une revalorisation salariale
plusieurs actions sont menées dans
plusieurs sites de l'enseigne de
bricolage à Strasbourg Xavier Gaspard le
délégué syndical a démarré une grève de
la fin hier à 13h aux Clayes-sous-Bois à
Marseille Saint-Loup à Reims et à
Béziers les salariés ont décidé
d'occuper plusieurs magasins toute la
nuit dernière et aux Clayes-sous-Bois
justement certains d'entre eux nous ont
envoyé une vidéo on regarde bonjour à
tous on est de retour dans notre hôtel 5
étoiles donc ce matin pain au chocolat
croissant
surtout granola pour ceux qui veulent
enfin la vie est belle quoi
pour la suite d'autres nocturnes sont
prévues dans les 87 magasins restants en
France pour cette action du côté des
Clayes-sous-Bois le chiffre du jour
c'est 500 pourquoi 500 c'est le nombre
de jours restants avant le début des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de 2024
pour rappel les jeux démarre en France
le 26 juillet 2024 et plusieurs sites
les accueilleront dans les Yvelines on
peut citer notamment le Vélodrome et le
Golf National de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ou encore le
château de Versailles pour les épreuves
équestres et pour ceux qui n'ont pas
encore pu réserver leur place sachez que
les inscriptions pour la seconde phase
de vente des Jeux olympiques de Paris
2024 démarre demain mercredi 15 mars et
ce jusqu'au 20 avril de table auprès de
nos invités les yeux les jeux les JO ça
vous intéresse est-ce que vous avez
essayé d'avoir une petite place pour ces
JO ouais et vous avez réussi du coup
pour l'instant lorsque ça a été très
difficile cette première phase est-ce
que les JO en tant que jeune du
territoire yvelinois il va y avoir des
épreuves sur le territoire albino est-ce
que ça ça vous intéresse est-ce que ça
va être impatient de les voir alors moi
ça m'intéressait surtout que moi je suis
versaillé donc on pourra suivre les
épreuves équestres on pourra surtout
suivre le marathon qui va passer par
Versailles donc c'est quand même
important vous serez dans les tribunes
sûrement oui ok donc pour ces Jeux
Olympiques qui arrivent donc dans 500
jours et date dans 500 jours un tout
pile ce sera le la cérémonie d'ouverture
il y a la porte d'entrée de notre studio
qui va sans doute s'ouvrir à la volée il
y a un petit peu de vent en ce moment du
côté du studio alors on va on va
poursuivre avec du sport avec du sport
toujours vous parliez de Versailles
sachez que le FC Versailles a remporté
hier soir son match contre le FC Borgo
ils ont mené 1-0 et reprennent ainsi la
première place au classement en National
l'équipe versaillesse est toujours en
course pour une montée en Ligue 2 en fin
de saison on termine avec une bonne
nouvelle pour le tourisme dans les
Yvelines tout à fait le département des
Yvelines à publier aujourd'hui les
chiffres de l'année 2022 la
fréquentation décide culturels étant
hausse de 95% par rapport à l'année 2021
à la première place le château de
Versailles qui cumulent plus de 6
millions 900000 visiteurs en 2022 suivi
du parc zoologique et de loisirs de
Thoiry avec 640000 visiteurs
après des années difficiles un Lio au
covid-19 merci beaucoup original rage
pour toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi près de chez
vous vous êtes témoin d'une information
d'un fait qui vous fait réagir n'hésitez
pas le dire sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news dans
l'actualité ce sera demain la 8e journée
de mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites même si ministre des
Transports Clément bonne a affirmé ce
matin qu'il n'y aurait pas de nouvelles
journées noires ça risque d'être
compliqué demain dans de nombreux
secteurs à quoi faut-il à quoi faut-il
s'attendre dans les Yvelines et les
moments de réponse avec Michael ennemi
Doro
de nombreux secteurs vont se mobiliser
ce mercredi 15 mars contre la réforme
des retraites et les Yvelines seront
impactées dans les transports la RATP
s'attend un trafic perturbé sur les RER
et recommande le télétravail il faudra
s'ammer de patience sur les quais 3 rera
sur 4 circuleuront mercredi
l'interconnexion sur un maintenu à
Nanterre Préfecture pour le RER B et C
compter 2 trains sur 3 en circulation le
trafic sera également perturbé sur les
trains de la région parisienne il y aura
trois trains sur 4 sur la ligne N il y
aura deux trains sur 3 pour la ligne J
et l le trafic sera quant à lui normal
sur la ligne U pour les bus le trafic
devrait être quasi normal dans les
Yvelines du côté de l'enseignement des
perturbations sont attendues dans les
écoles les collèges et les lycées mais
aussi dans les accueils périscolaires et
les services de cantine
la suite de ce 7 8 avec la première
interview on le disait il y a
Charles-Antoine albizetti qui est élève
en classe de défense et de sécurité
globale c'est un dispositif qui est
proposé du côté du lycée Hoche à
Versailles c'est un dispositif même
national un proposé par le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale c'est classe sont
une initiative voilà l'initiative d'une
équipe pédagogique qui permet de
sensibiliser les élèves qui le
souhaitent au problématiques de
citoyenneté de défense de géopolitique
et donc je le disais vous êtes élève
dans l'une de ces classes alors chaque
classe doit être parrainée par une unité
militaire quelle est la vôtre du coup
donc la gendarmerie nationale donc
particulièrement la gendarmerie
départementale des Yvelines donc qui
parraine cette classe du côté du lycée
Hoche alors au programme de l'année il y
a de nombreuses visites du coup c'est
des sorties scolaires auprès de la
gendarmerie ou c'est un peu plus global
ça va être des sorties scolaires donc
auprès de la gendarmerie ou si on est
gendarmes qui ont présenté des
dispositifs dans notre lycée mais en
particulier donc par exemple avec le 11
novembre même prochainement avec le 8
mai donc on peut aussi également tenir
des discours devant des ministres des
mers ou encore des préfets c'est déjà
pris la parole devant justement des
ministres des mers des préfets oui tout
à fait donc au monument aux morts de
Versailles donc notamment face à
Jean-Noël Barrault le maire de
Versailles ou encore le préfet des
Yvelines je mets le barreau qui était le
député de la deuxième circonscription
des Yvelines qui est l'actuel ministre
de la transition numérique quel type de
visite vous avez pu faire aussi depuis
le début de l'année alors on a pu aller
à Vélizy donc avec la base aérienne de
Vélizy ou encore à Mania le hameau avec
donc le poste à cheval ou encore le
psychique donc le peloton de sécurité
d'investigation de la gendarmerie ou
encore des présentations donc de la BMO
qui présente leur forme donc leur
voiture qui permettent
donc d'échapper aux Fillard mais de
différentes types de gendarmerie avec
bien sûr la gendarmerie classique donc
la gendarmerie départementale il y a une
visite qui vous a plu s'intéresser
qu'une autre alors la base aérienne de
Vélizy qui est quand même très
impressionnante parce que c'est la donc
de la région Île-de-France et donc c'est
très impressionnant parce qu'en fait
quasiment toutes les 5 minutes on a un
nouveau décollage d'un hélicoptère et on
peut penser que tous les hélicoptères
qui sont de chez nous mais c'est pas
forcément de la gendarmerie nationale
mais très régulièrement le président de
la République prend son avion sur place
il l'avait pris avec le président
ukrainien à volodime ski vous avez une
question à l'origine oui ce type de
classe combien de temps ça dure ce que
c'est sur un an où on peut continuer ça
se prolonge alors déjà sur cette année
en fait c'est déjà un an et sauf qu'en
fait on est les Calais donc on sait pas
encore sur la suite sachant qu'on est en
partenaire avec le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et le ministère
des armées mais donc par la suite on va
continuer à participer à de nombreuses
cérémonies en faisant des discours ou en
simplement étant dans dans les rangs
mais on en connaît pas pour la suite et
on entend la réponse des ministères et
ça représente à peu près combien de
sorties ou de visites par an alors pour
l'instant on est à peu près une
vingtaine et on compte également faire
d'autres dans la France notamment au
Mans on souhaite aller au deuxième Rima
puisque on a un projet que l'on porte
avec le prix armée jeunesse qui
proposait par le ministère des armées où
l'on défend donc on va graver le nom
d'un ancien élève mort au combat donc au
chat dans 1789 est-ce que ça vous
dernière petite question est-ce que vous
avez aussi des cours en plus des visites
alors oui tout à fait on a un professeur
d'histoire donc monsieur Chauvin qui
nous fait des cours d'histoire sur la
guerre donc de l'Antiquité jusqu'à nos
jours surtout que l'on voit que
actuellement la guerre frappe à nos
portes justement où qu'est-ce qui vous a
attiré dans cette classe alors c'est une
classe qui se fait au lycée vous l'avez
intégré dès la seconde du coup alors
donc normalement c'est en troisième mais
nous que au lycée Hoche c'est en seconde
et donc on avait une présentation de la
part d'une dame du SNU et donc moi j'ai
tout de suite
et donc on a été tout de suite scotché
donc on est 30 élèves répartis sur
différentes classes de seconde et donc
je trouve que c'est important donc de
connaître des informations sur l'armée
sur plein de choses enfin qui paraissent
peut-être pas importantes à nos yeux
mais donc la base aérienne enfin tout ce
qui me permet de nous défendre à nos
yeux c'est très important et mais aussi
enfin c'est aussi de l'engagement côté
citoyen donc voilà vous disiez de
l'engagement avec une guerre qui est
revenue en Europe se confier en Ukraine
qui maintenant un an à débuter et ça
prend encore plus de sens pour vous cet
engagement aujourd'hui tout à fait
surtout que on sait qu'en 2025 un quart
des effectifs de la gendarmerie
partiront à la retraite donc enfin ils
ont besoin d'avoir une relève et donc
notamment auprès de la jeunesse
du coup vous avez aussi participé cette
année il me semble au prix armé jeunesse
ça consiste en quoi ce prix donc cette
fois on va déposer notre candidature
auprès du prix armée jeunesse donc ça
consiste à un projet donc nous ce qu'on
appelle le projet gerloto donc c'est la
personne on va rendre hommage donc il
est mort au Tchad malheureusement en
1980 et donc ça consiste à raconter tout
ce qu'on a fait durant l'année donc les
sorties les cérémonies mais aussi en
partie point des films sur la guerre
donc c'est différentes choses et on va
tenter de gagner ce prêt à mes jeunesse
pour les décisions 2023 on vous souhaite
bonne chance une dernière question du
coup est-ce que ça suscite aussi l'envie
de s'engager après là vous êtes engagé
au sein de cette classe peut-être au
sein de la gendarmerie au sein d'autres
forces de l'ordre mais ce qu'il y a une
volonté d'engagement par la suite alors
déjà tout à fait moi je vais déjà faire
le service national universel en juin
qui est proposé donc par le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et par la suite je
vais voir le temps mais pourquoi pas
m'engager donc dans la journée ou en
plus large dans les armées donc avec
notamment lire ses gènes donc qui est
une donc les ingénieurs donc dans la
criminalité principalement très
rapidement l'intègre commence cette
classe commence ça se passe comment
qui est plutôt une école littéraire mais
principalement dans l'armée ou sinon
avec un diplôme d'ingénieur en intégrant
ensuite l'air CGN voilà mais pour la
classe préparatoire la classe de
sécurité globale du coup il faut aller
juste en fait c'était notre souhait si
on voulait on pouvait participer il y
avait pas de règles précis voilà c'est
facultatif tout à fait c'est une option
bon ben merci en tout cas d'être venu en
parler sur ce plateau Charles-Antoine
albizetti je rappelle un élève dans la
classe de défense et de sécurité globale
et du côté du lycée Hoche c'est à
Versailles la suite à présent dans le 7
8 de cette série toute la semaine sur TV
78 nous suivons les aventures de Fabien
Lambert depuis octobre il est le premier
Eco garde professionnel des Yvelines
salariés par la commune de Beynes
l'agent veille aux espaces verts
naturels lutter notamment contre les
dépôts sauvages c'est une problématique
de plus en plus présente pour les
communes et les collectivités reportages
de Mathilde de Franco
[Musique]
moi aussi signalé la présence d'un dépôt
sauvage dans un champ à proximité de la
commune on va aujourd'hui s'y rendre
pour essayer de retrouver des preuves et
le propriétaire du dépôt on y va
[Musique]
donc voici le dépôt malheureusement il y
a des gens qui se permettent de jeter
leurs déchets dans la nature donc je
vais essayer de retrouver des preuves
pour essayer d'identifier l'auteur du
fait c'est énormément des déchets de
chantier des gravats voilà ou des
déchets verts il faut savoir que les
déchets verts c'est pas forcément bon
aussi pour l'environnement on pourrait
se dire que c'est biodégradable mais ça
fait pas très propre comme vous le voyez
ici et puis ça apporte aussi des espèces
différentes de celles présentes en forêt
qui peuvent nuire à l'écosystème
[Musique]
vous travaillez avec aussi énormément de
partenaires ça peut être la gendarmerie
l'ONU les égaux gars mais aussi tous les
administrés et puis les agriculteurs sur
le territoire puisqu'ils
à proximité des forêts ou à proximité
des soins communaux donc on est là
vraiment pour apporter notre soutien aux
administrés aux agriculteurs et on n'est
pas là pour le but n'est pas de la
répression mais vraiment la
sensibilisation
donc
maintenant on va se rendre sur les temps
de LED pour surveiller les abords de la
rivière et de l'étang pour voir s'il y a
pas des déchets des défauts voilà ou des
pêcheurs qui n'auraient pas forcément le
permis de pêche
la suite demain dans le 7 8 et c'est à
présent l'heure de notre page culturel
sur TV 78
[Musique]
et on parle à présent du festival à tout
bout de champ la 21e édition vient de
débuter du côté de Manille aliamo
spectacle et concerts sont au programme
à la Maison de l'Environnement
l'estaminet et aussi du côté du pôle
Blaise Pascal on en parle avec deux
invités qui nous ont rejoint au plateau
Émilie Dubuc responsable du service
culturel de Magny-les-Hameaux bonsoir
c'est vous pardon et Cécile Vandervoort
ça se prononce vendeur vrode voilà bon
comme ça on précise les choses d'emblée
et vous êtes vous chargés de l'action
culturelle et de l'action avec les
publics dans la commune de Manille liamo
une petite question on va commencer avec
vous Emie Dubuc le principe du festival
à tout bout de champ qui allait-il le
festival donc la fête à 21e édition donc
c'est un festival qui s'adresse à tous
les publics publics famille jeunes
publics en temps scolaire Hortense
scolaire qui s'étale sur un petit peu
plus de deux semaines donc presque trois
semaines
avec des spectacles que l'on va trouver
autant pour les tout-petits à partir de
4-5 ans ou voire un peu plus grand et
puis pour toute la famille de manière
générale donc on va avoir notamment les
spectacles pour la toute petite enfance
qu'on joue également dans les crèches
et puis en salle puisqu'on a trois
salles dans lesquelles on fait jouer des
spectacles la Maison de l'Environnement
l'estaminet et le pôle musical Blaise
Pascal mais leur l'objectif c'est de les
éveiller leur donner le goût justement
de la musique dès le plus jeune âge
parce que ça s'adresse vraiment à des
six mois il y a des programmations même
six mois donc des six mois alors après
le but c'est aussi de créer un échange à
la fois avec la avec la famille avec les
frères et soeurs avec les personnes qui
les accompagnent et puis de leur
permettre d'avoir accès à différentes
différentes formes de spectacles donc ça
peut aller de d'un spectacle très
sensoriel comme un concert un concert
rock reggae ou
ensemble en septembre même si là on a
compris que c'était sur trois lieux
c'est aussi une belle occasion de fêter
cet anniversaire on imagine en septembre
dernier mais voilà c'est effectivement
le fait aussi toute l'année tout au long
de la saison
et puis voilà avec tout un ensemble de
spectacles on retrouve de toute façon
sur le sur les deux salles et puis à
l'extérieur donc sur les sur les
différents lieux
donc là on démarre avec les tout-petits
donc avec la White Company qui arrive
avec le spectacle briquet broc en forme
nomade qu'on organise dans les crèches
et au pôle Blaise Pascal et puis avec
les frères Brico qui vont jouer samedi
donc il va être le premier spectacle
proposé aux familles ensuite à partir de
mercredi on passe sur d'autres types de
spectacle que je vais envoyer juste
briquet broc à l'écran allez-y c'est ça
Brico le du coup samedi on a aussi un
atelier juste avant le spectacle donc ça
ça s'adresse à aux familles à partir de
trois ans donc ensuite on a le donc le
mercredi 22 mars on a deux spectacles en
parallèle donc un premier pour les plus
petits organisé avec le réseau des
médiathèques incantant-yvelines dans le
cadre de babillage c'est un spectacle
accompagné d'une exposition donc c'est à
partir de 12 mois c'est un moyen de
plonger les tout-petits dans l'art
moderne donc avec la présentation de
trois tableaux donc la candine ski
arpent Garcia suivi par une par une
exposition où les petits sont amenés à
toucher manipuler construire des
construire des tableaux et donc en
parallèle on a le ce même jour à 15h et
17h les grands chambres pour les petits
donc c'est une création musicale
créé par une avec une troupe d'enfants
donc qui s'inscrit en début d'année avec
des ateliers qui commencent dès le mois
de novembre accompagné par une
intervenante musique et une intervenante
théâtre
tous les styles sont les gens présentés
notamment avec ce spectacle là par le
biais de la danse du chant du théâtre
donc voilà
invité aussi musical qu'est-ce qui vous
avoue donner le goût de la musique petit
peut-être est-ce que vous en souvenez ce
que vous avez souvenir non c'est pas de
ce genre d'événement par exemple
le goût de la musique au plus petit
alors moi j'avais aussi repéré une date
il y en a beaucoup on peut retrouver
d'ailleurs toute la programmation sur le
site de Magny-les-Hameaux qui a
peut-être s'afficher dans un instant en
bas de l'écran j'avais vu qu'il y avait
aussi des spectacles qui mêlaient reggae
rock on peut se dire ce genre de musique
pour les pour les plus petits c'est pas
forcément adapté au plus petit alors là
l'idée c'est efficacé peut-être ces
idées reçues c'est de les ouvrir aussi à
ces styles de musique de reggae de rock
en l'occurrence oui alors après le jeune
public est vraiment enfin il n'y a pas
de forme adaptée enfin si ce n'est après
dans le format et dans le la manière de
s'adresser s'adresser aux tout petit
maintenant les enfants sont aussi
naturellement enfin peuvent partir dans
beaucoup beaucoup d'univers donc
là pour le coup sur le sur la partie
rock reggae donc on a la compagnie enfin
le spectacle de trombinéopède qui vient
jouer sur donc mercredi mercredi sur
mercredi
on a également le spectacle Little Rock
Story sur l'histoire du rock pour un
petit peu plus grand qui reprend
plein d'univers et le balmar Maï sur un
univers encore différent ou voilà on les
enfants partent assez facilement dans
ces dans différentes formes de toute
façon
sans forcément que que
en ayant en tout cas toute la famille
qui peut s'y retrouver aussi et les
adultes s'y retrouvent largement
sera le dimanche 2 avril du côté de
l'estaminet sera l'occasion de venir
danser en famille et de clôturer comme
il se doit cette 21e édition du Festival
Juste sur les tarifs ça va être 5 à 15
euros selon si on est manicois ou pas
voilà des tarifs différents qu'on peut
retrouver aussi sur le site internet et
ce qu'il faut réserver en avance plutôt
vous conseiller
alors pour les réservations du coup on
peut réserver directement sur le site du
kiosque de 50 ans en Yvelines ou sinon
par téléphone ou l'adresse mail donc
tout écrit sur la brochure ou sur le
site internet de la ville de
Magny-les-Hameaux donc le site internet
qui s'est affiché et kiosque c'est k
iosq point sqy.fr voilà pour noter les
spectateurs aussi qui nous regardent
merci en tout cas toutes les deux d'être
venu en parler en plateau et je rappelle
la 21e édition de ce festival à tout
bout de chance c'est jusqu'au 2 avril à
Manille liamo avec des spectacles des
concerts qui sont au programme sur trois
lieux Maison de l'Environnement et
également au pôle musical Blaise Pascal
en face de vous un invité qui est avec
nous depuis le début de l'émission je
lui disais c'est Samuel Samia qui est
bassiste de saymani instinct trio de
jazz originaire des Yvelines et je le
disais tout à l'heure vous serez vous du
côté d'Élancourt il y aura aussi une
date dimanche qu'on va annoncer dans un
instant mais à Élancourt sera samedi
pour la fête de la réouverture de la
médiathèque des 7 morts jouer pour la
réouverture d'un lieu culturel qui a été
fermé au puits pendant plusieurs mois
pour des travaux ça vous fait quoi c'est
intéressant pour vous ah oui on l'a déjà
fait du coup pour je crois que c'est un
voisin de mémoire enfin d'aller dernière
effectivement c'est un lieu d'animation
bah c'est pour contre gens que la
musique c'est sa vie aussi du coup c'est
pas que une déranger de céder dans une
médiathèque c'est aussi des éléments
ayant alors ces mesures c'est un trio
trois personnes alors vous êtes le
bassiste il y a aussi Yann garrot le
batteur est aussi Emilio Anto Fermo le
guitariste alors pour se faire une idée
on va écouter un extrait d'un clip
c'est she's anywhere and nowhere
[Musique]
parce que on est plus
les notes sont plus universelles que les
paroles donc on a choisi effectivement
de pouvoir s'exprimer par la musique et
les mélodies qui sont choisies plutôt
que les paroles tout simplement et le
jazz alors pourquoi est-ce que c'est
c'est une musique qui trouve encore son
public est-ce que c'est pas une musique
juste de spécialiste le jazz en fait
c'est là pour le compteur c'est on
essaie de casser les barrières justement
parce que jazz enfin déjà ça veut tout
dire c'est toutes les musiques en fait
toutes les musiques viennent
probablement
soit du gospel soit du jazz enfin c'est
un petit peu donc on casse on casse les
limites donc il y a du binaire il y a du
il y a du ternaire comme je vous disais
il y a toutes sortes de pulsations
toutes sortes d'ambiance par rapport à
différents morceaux qui ont proposé
effectivement et vous arrivez à
intéresser toutes les générations
justement sur le jazz justement on a
fait plusieurs concepts notamment à
médiathèque la dernière fois c'était les
gens étaient vraiment surpris parce que
c'est jazz mais c'est c'est de la
musique
donc ça varie chacun sa propre
sensibilité par rapport à la musique
Régine est-ce que justement vous vous
produisez aussi en dehors des frontières
du de des Yvelines est-ce que vous avez
déjà fait des concerts
le groupe une séance je vais pas mal au
début notamment enfin dans la fameuse
rue des Lombards aux ducs il y a des il
y a pas mal de concerts qui ont lieu tu
peux partout en France tout à fait et là
donc du coup on a Chartres le dimanche
pour le festival Jazz
pour samedi vous serez à Chartres le
dimanche en dehors des Yvelines mais bon
voilà vous êtes originaire que vous êtes
ici bien sûr pour pour en parler vous
influences à vous et au groupe est-ce
qu'il y en a qui qui ressortent dans
dans les dans les les productions du
coup
oui nécessairement déjà on inspiré des
trio peut-être qui ont marqué l'histoire
du jazz pour ma part c'est plus moderne
c'est tout ce qui est par exemple
chicoréen électriquement ou
acoustiquement qui par exemple mais
c'est aussi des trio un peu plus
modernes comme nec plus qui sont des
trio très très moderne aujourd'hui qui
sont plus jazz fusion Jason mélange-t-il
et est-ce que alors le jazz ça laisse
pas aussi sur les sur les scènes à une
part d'improvisation ça vous arrive
aussi régulièrement
oui c'est en fait les morceaux se
présentent effectivement comme une
structure jazz il y a l'intro le thème
est exposé et ensuite effectivement
chacun la possibilité de s'exprimer
aussi bien la guitare à la base que la
batterie en fonction des éléments puis
ensuite on rejoint le thème puis la fin
le régime vous aviez une autre question
l'autre question c'est pourquoi avoir
choisi un titre en anglais
voilà le titre
sont tout le temps en anglais non pas
forcément
le premier album du groupe est-ce qu'il
y a de nouveau projet musicaux
très vite avant un courant 2023 on
espère début 2014 effectivement il sera
essentiellement des titres de cet album
qui seront joués qui seront samedi ou de
nouvelles de nouvelles composition
effectivement mais oui c'est
principalement des titres du de la bonne
actuelle donc on pourra vous écouter du
côté de la médiathèque des 7 mars samedi
pour le trio saymani à l'occasion je le
disais de la fête de la réouverture de
la médiathèque qui a lieu samedi du côté
d'Élancourt merci Samuel Samira d'être
venu en parler en plateau d'être venu
présenté ce groupe saymani un trio de
jazz je disais originaire des Yvelines
watts présents à présent parler de
cinéma avec les passionnés de
court-métrage qui avait rendez-vous à
aux Clayes-sous-Bois du côté de l'espace
Philippe vrai pour la 11e édition du
festival les clefs du cinéma on se filme
d'une durée allant de 8 minutes à 20
minutes été présenté le public a pu
visionner les oeuvres et profiter d'un
échange privilégié avec les réalisateurs
au palmarès le premier prix du jury a
été décerné au réalisateur Jeanneke
Tarkovski pour son film je veille sur
toi et le prix du public a été attribué
au réalisateur Christophe Witters pour
son court-métrage breton on écoute le
président du jury l'acteur émetteur en
scène Alexis Michalik ainsi qu'un
réalisateur primé au micro de Julien
Leroy surtout une opportunité pour eux
de de présenter leur film à un public
nouveau qui ne connaissent pas et de
d'entendre les réactions et de
évidemment de recevoir un prix de se
sentir légitimer de et puis après prix
ça nous donne peut-être les clés pour
obtenir des nouveaux financements pour
un nouveau film j'en suis ravi pour le
film pour l'équipe c'est
une récompense on va dire collective
c'est voilà à la fois du côté de la
salle qui a voté pour le film et à la
fois du côté de l'équipe notre travail
récompensé c'est l'émotion voilà on
s'est battu pour ça et ça le fait quoi
il veut devoir dimanche après la messe
il a dit pourquoi c'est pour rire tu as
encore fait une connerie
ils veulent l'envoyer au collège ils en
ont parlé avec l'instituteur ce serait
le seul de la classe à y aller
le certificat ça suffit pas
et à présent on va parler d'une
exposition le palais du roi de Rome de
Rambouillet à accueille son expression
cabane c'est jusqu'au 14 mai 2023 je
sais pas si vous jouiez avec des cabanes
petit dans les bois je sais pas du tout
autour de la table non pas du tout
toujours vous avez pas eu cette chance
qui renvoie à l'enfance et cette plongée
c'est une plongée dans l'univers bien
sûr de ses abris de toutes sortes avec
une exposition qui devrait à mon avis
séduire toutes les familles Céline
Charles pour la découverte
qu'elle soit de jardin du pêcheur ou
encore perché dans les arbres les
cabanons de cesse de faire rêver les
petits et les grands
[Musique]
tout le monde en a au moins fait une
dans sa vie que ce soit dans les des
espaces intérieurs sous des couvertures
ou sous la table du salon avec la nappe
qui dépasse c'est une thématique que
l'on voit qui se développe aussi dans
tout ce qui est tourisme après plusieurs
mois de réflexion le palais du roi de
Rome de Rambouillet vous invite à
découvrir son exposition ouvrage cabane
d'artistes dessin ou encore maquette
viennent mettre à l'honneur cet abri
insolite cette oeuvre est une oeuvre
d'Isabelle Bond qui est une artiste
contemporaine qui s'appelle les trois
amis elle expose dans l'exposition 3 de
ses créations et donc ce qui est
intéressant avec le travail d'Isabelle
bon c'est qu'elle travaille les cabanes
en miniature principalement en fil de
fer et utiliser également des matériaux
naturels comme ici le tarlatan de coton
et puis voilà ça ça permet de remettre
l'homme à une petite échelle par rapport
à la grandeur de la nature c'est une
exposition qui va vraiment parler à tout
le monde qui développe plein de
thématiques donc la cabane d'architecte
la cabane d'artistes la cabane rituel la
et l'enfant c'est les cabanes de métiers
une exposition aussi dédiée aux adeptes
de cachettes dont l'imaginaire sera mis
à contribution ici dans cet espace les
enfants peuvent créer leur propre cabane
donc on a mis à disposition différents
morceaux de tissu de couleur assez
neutre ainsi que des ainsi que des
coussins pour pouvoir aménager
l'intérieur et on propose également dans
la salle différents ouvrages que les
enfants peuvent lire plusieurs temps
forts sont prévus jusqu'à la fermeture
de l'exposition le 14 mai 2023 prochain
rendez-vous une visite avec un guide
conférencier le 26 mars
on a été rejoint en plateau par
Véronique Iturbide monsor Véronique ça
va bien ça va très bien et comme chaque
mardi c'est vos insolites que vous
présentez au téléspectateurs TV 78
c'est ce sont même vos insolites et on
commence Véronique avec la sortie du
nouveau Guide Michelin qui a fait grand
bruit on a entendu beaucoup parlé de la
perte de la troisième étoile de Guy
Savoie mais dans les Yvelines qu'est-ce
qu'on peut retenir de ce guide Michelin
2023 et bien moi j'ai retenu que dans
les Yvelines nous avions six étoiles
donc trois concentrés à Versailles mais
gênez-vous alors voulez-vous savoir
lesquels bien sûr si vous me dites NON
je suis un petit peu déçu alors on y va
merci
au grand contrôle on a Gabri les
ravazzios qui est je la prends du sel
italienne mais bon c'est pas Gordon
Ramsès
et puis évidemment la table du 11 avec
Jean-Baptiste Lavergne moradini qui que
j'avais reçu en vibre d'ailleurs en 2018
quand il avait écrit un livre voilà qui
est un petit qu'un jeune qui qui marche
très bien qui a aussi le Bistrot du 11
voilà pour les trois étoilés versaillais
on a vu donc les restaurants étoilés
urinois s'afficher on a la petite liste
alors parmi cette liste il y a aussi un
étoilé un insolite c'est l'étoile verte
qu'est-ce que ça récompense alors en
fait l'étoile verte c'est une sorte de
label qui a été donc créée en 2020 donc
toujours par le guide Michelin et qui en
fait
demande enfin pour l'avoir pour
l'obtenir cette étoile verte il faut
bien sûr être éco-responsable
locavore comment dire chasse au
gaspillage alimentaire
durabilité tout enfin dormitique en
environnemental circuit court voire tout
ce que tout ce qu'on aime en ce moment
tout ce qu'il faut faire voilà alors là
la personne qui a gagné qui a eu cette
étoile verte elle s'appelle Sibel idlow
c'est une chef américaine elle vient de
San Francisco elle est mariée à français
et son restaurant s'appelle la ruche
d'ailleurs je crois qu'on en parlera sur
cette même chaîne bientôt un reportage
on a eu quelques images en
avant-première du lieu c'est du côté de
Gambais on aura un reportage
effectivement très prochainement et
juste pour terminer ce sont ce lieu elle
aurait la 2000 m² de potager 80% de la
production se retrouve à sa table elle
fait son pain elle fait son beurre et ça
Ricote voilà donc elle coche plusieurs
cases
déjà pour aller pour aller dans ce
restaurant
faut toujours attendre un petit peu dans
la vie
négligeable pour ces restaurants on va
continuer Véronique avec une vente aux
enchères historiques qui a lieu ce
dimanche à Versailles il y avait
notamment une boucle de cheveux de Louis
XVII le dauphin le dauphin une page
d'écriture aussi un toujours de Louis
x17 si j'ai pas de bêtises mais c'est
surtout une lettre historique qui a été
comme on dit le clou de la vente tout à
fait alors cette vente elle s'est passé
chez Jean-Pierre hosenac
commissaire-priseur avenue Saint-Cloud à
Versailles et trois fois par an cette
commissaire préserve organise des ventes
spécialisées autour de la royauté ou des
objets de la Révolution par exemple vous
voyez mais alors ce qu'il dit c'est
qu'il y a des choses très chères on peut
aussi avoir un lot à 100 euros il y en a
pour tout le monde voilà alors là cette
fois-ci le Cloud c'était justement cette
lettre c'est la seule lettre qui reste
de Robespierre qu'il a écrit à son ami
Danton pour le
le réconforter parce que dans ton venait
de perdre sa femme en couche et donc
comme un très bon ami qu'il était il lui
écrit une lettre extrêmement
réconfortante et d'ailleurs je peux vous
en lire un petit morceau si vous voulez
on a vu la lettre s'affiche à l'écran
mais allez-y déjà non
pas du tout
mon cher Danton si dans les seuls
malheurs qui puissent ébranler une âme
tel que la tienne la certitude d'avoir
un ami tendre et dévoué peut t'offrir
quelques consolations je te la présente
et il ajoute dans cette lettre je t'aime
plus que jamais et jusqu'à la mort
et c'est étonnant mais je vais vous
laisser continuer je vais vous laisser
ça c'était écrit le 15 février 1793
imaginez-vous qu'un an après presque
jour pour jour qu'est-ce qui qu'elle
bouge le pique Robespierre ordonne que
ce pauvre Danton soit guillotiné alors
moi des amis comme ça merci mais non
merci voilà mais il faut savoir qu'à
l'époque déjà la rivalité entre les deux
hommes commençaient à poindre et
apparemment cette petite pointe arrangée
après
ça a l'air
cette histoire
on va terminer c'est très moche je vous
ai coupé la parole mais elle a été vendu
218000 €. la mèche de cheveux du petit
dauphin avec un autographe de
Marie-Antoinette et Louis XVI 23000
c'est acheté par un collectionneur
normand c'est un collectionneur parisien
qui a acheté la lettre et il y avait
aussi cette page d'écriture du Louis
Charles qui s'exerce à écrire son prénom
à signer qui a été vendu 18000 euros
voilà voilà
on termine avec du cinéma une
avant-première le 21 mars à Versailles
avec un acteur yvelinois et quel acteur
gens du jardin
alors une avant-première à Versailles le
mardi 21 mars à 20 vous avez donc
l'équipe du film Jean Dujardin le film
s'appelle sur les chemins noirs pardon
de Denis Humbert il y aura aussi le
producteur du film qui s'appelle Mathieu
voilà enfin ça c'est mes feuilles je
comprends plus rien mais
alors ce film en fait il a été adapté
librement d'un livre de Sylvain Tesson
qui a aussi écrit le scénario j'imagine
avec le Denis Humbert Sylvain Tesson qui
a eu un terrible accident il y a
quelques années et qui après a effectué
une très longue marche une espèce de
reconnaissance de soi de quête de
plongée dans la ruralité et il a fait à
pied du Mercantour au Cotentin il a
traversé vraiment la France à pied et
donc ce film est inadaptation de du
livre voilà et j'ai un dernier petit
truc de dernière minute
faut soutenir le cinéma franchement
c'est important et surtout classe c'est
une bonne nouvelle c'est le Cyrano qui
organise une séance spéciale pas de
vaincre ou mourir le dimanche 19 mars à
18h30 avec un nouveau l'équipe du film
pourquoi pour les récompenser parce que
le Cyrano a eu les meilleurs scores pour
ce film en meilleur score de France en
janvier février c'est une histoire de
pendant la guerre de Vendée de révolte
paysannes etc donc voilà c'est riche il
y a beaucoup de choses à avoir au cinéma
et il faut en profiter donc cette date
ce sera le 19 mars
et le 21 mars Jean Dujardin voilà en
chair et en
gastronomie lettre de Robespierre cinéma
qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus intérêt
intéressé Samuel un peu tout pour ces
enfants insolites
de réapprendre cette histoire de
Robespierre et de Danton
oui je la connaissais mais vous avez
toujours à porter un petit plus donc
merci je suis forte merci beaucoup merci
Véronique on vous retrouve mardi alors
vous étiez pas là la semaine dernière
mais on vous retrouve bien mardi
prochain vous le confirmez de tv70 et on
pourrait peut-être trouver des des
objets insolites sur sur ce lieu la
foire de Chatou ça vous parle
des objets insolites peut-être pourquoi
pas mais en tout cas c'est on va dire un
must et un temps pour un lieu
incontournable pour les passionnés les
passionnés d'antiquités de brocante
cette fois se déroule jusqu'à dimanche
du côté de l'île des Impressionnistes de
Chatou on peut y trouver des objets
d'art des livres ou encore de la
peinture 300 exposants à son sur place
pour cette 104e édition est près de 30
000 visiteurs sont attendus le reportage
de Julien le roi
donc les petites les deux petits
le rendez-vous des chineurs et de retour
amateur Dar ou simple curieux se
retrouvent sur l'île des
Impressionnistes pour la Foire de Chatou
jusqu'au 19 Mars 103 argenterie meuble
ou encore sculpture ce que toi pêle-mêle
des petits bibelots bon marché aux
pièces de musée chacun petit trouver son
bonheur c'est un voyage dans le temps
nous passons d'un stand dans un autre
d'un univers en tout autre univers on
peut trouver de tout sur la foire de
château on peut trouver des objets à 5
euros des objets
bien plus cher
sans limite de prix quoi pratiquement
présent depuis une quinzaine d'années
sur la brocante cet antiquaire propose
des articles anciens venus du monde
entier chaque pièce parfois vendue
plusieurs milliers d'euros s'accompagne
d'un certificat d'authenticité vous avez
ici un vase gousse d'ail chinois de 2000
ans d'âge en bronze très très belle
patine qui était réservée aux offrandes
à cette époque-là avec des vins de
France
moment de convivialité et de partage
autour de l'histoire des objets à chaque
édition près de 30 000 visiteurs arpente
les allées parfois à la recherche de la
perle rare ça fait 30 ans qu'on habite
sur la région parisienne et donc tous
les ans et deux fois par an on vient on
vient à la foire de Chatou trouver des
objets insolites et des antiquités sur
le sur les objets sportifs c'est un peu
comme les pour les paysans quoi c'est le
salon agricole des brocs et on a plein
de potes on s'achète entre nous étant à
Granville j'ai beaucoup de clients qui
sont à Saint-Germain-en-Laye dans le 70
dans le vin dans l'ouest de Paris et qui
descendent sur la Bretagne donc en fait
c'est un suivi c'est un suivi de
clientèle puis voilà près de 300
exposants professionnels participent à
74e foire de château à vioshiner la
prochaine édition aura lieu en septembre
[Musique]
en 19h à 18h48 bientôt l'heure de passer
à table avec l'astuce du chef chaque
mardi sont les conseils du pro pour
briller chez vous en cuisine petit tour
de table parce que vous êtes fan de
cuisine libanaise
conquis en tout cas ce soir c'est Marc
Badaoui responsable du restaurant taska
mezzebar de Voisins-le-Bretonneux qui
nous présente une recette emblématique
libanaise c'est le caviar d'aubergine il
ouvre son astuce pour bien réutiliser la
sauce au tahiné régalez-vous
[Musique]
bonjour je suis Marc Badaoui je suis le
gérant du restaurant libanais taska
mezzebar à Voisins-le-Bretonneux et
aujourd'hui on va faire ensemble un
caviar d'aubergine
[Musique]
évidemment on commence avec l'aubergine
et avant de la mettre au four pour la
griller on va planter avec une
fourchette ou un couteau quelques
entailles ça va éviter qu'elle explose
au four
on va tout simplement venir gratter
le fond de l'aubergine c'est
complètement fondant
plus vous allez en mettre plus vous
allez avoir du goût de sésame plus ça va
être consistant et gourmand
[Musique]
like on a écrasé dans le sel
et qu'on va venir verser avec le jus de
citron et la pâte de sésame on va venir
ajouter de l'eau
un peu de mélange 4 épices
hop
voilà ça va énormément parfumer on va
mettre
nos aubergines je vais pas tout mettre
je vais en garder un peu
trop bon comme ça
mais on mélange ensuite vous pouvez
goûter et assaisonner à votre convenance
alors on va ensuite servir ça dans un
bol
hop là un petit peu de coriandre
un petit peu de persil
on badigeonne
d'un petit peu d'herbe on avait une
grenade qu'on a décortiquée petite
astuce la grenade avant de la
décortiquer faites la rouler sur votre
plan de travail comme ça on appuyant ça
fait décoller les grenades ensuite vous
la coupez en deux et puis vous prenez
une cuillère et vous prenez chaque
moitié et vous tapez dessus comme ça et
ça fait que ça tombe c'est beaucoup plus
rapide
[Musique]
je mets la grenade
petite astuce que je vous ai dit
rapidement au début faites bien la sauce
sésame à part comme ça si vous en reste
vous en faites pour de l'aubergine mixez
avec les pois chiches ça va vous donner
un ou mousse et ça vous servira
également de sauce pour agrémenter votre
plat principal
[Musique]
vous avez pris bonne note régime ce que
vous allez l'habitude de nous régaler en
rédaction donc peut-être le caviar
d'aubergine la prochaine fois je vais
essayer mais je pense que c'est quand
même assez compliqué mais je vais
essayer bien sûr merci en tout cas Marc
Badaoui de ce restaurant de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux c'est bientôt la
fin de ce 7 8 mais avant de vous laisser
un dernier coup d'oeil à la météo de
demain
[Musique]
un soleil timide c'est ce qui vous
attend pour la journée de demain demain
matin des éclaircis seront présentes sur
tout le département côté température il
fera à 5 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie Houdan
et Rambouillet il fera un tout petit peu
plus chaud du côté de Versailles avec 6
degrés pas de changement ce qui concerne
l'après-midi les températures seront
légèrement plus chaudes comptées 11
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan il
fera 10 degrés à Versailles Rambouillet
et ce mercredi 15 mars c'est là sainte
Louise voilà c'est la fin de ce 7 8
merci Véronique merci Samuel merci
également à Régine d'avoir été avec moi
pour cette émission vous retrouverez
demain Mathilde Franco à la présentation
d'une nouvelle édition belle soirée sur
TV 78
[Musique]